guys
they did it just like jack promised put
aside the copium because the smell of
gunfire and freedom has filled the air
once again cloud9 our region's one and
only major winners
are back in cs go
north america ladies and gentlemen
has been saved
what's that
gambit
[Music]
okay so before i dive into what
has to be the
weirdest piece of counter-strike news i
have ever delivered on a donat me i must
ask that you liked the video subscribe
to the channel and turn on notifications
north america once again has a top three
counter-strike roster in the world so
we're gonna be doing a lot more of these
i know what i said all right i know what
i said all right so after exiting the
king of shooters just over a year ago
following the highly publicized failure
of their so-called colossus roster
cloud9 are back in counter-strike why is
this a big deal
well it's a big deal because cloud9 have
a storied history in cs go they've been
around since almost the very beginning
of global offensive fielding beloved
rosters and providing homes to legends
prodigies and hopefuls alike they've
seen ups downs and everything in between
but let's not let any of this distract
us from the fact that faze clan blew a
15-11 lead in the cs go boston major
final on the final map inferno giving c9
and n a
their first major
we saw it from this position before he
cannot miss a single shot
guardian waits
patiently
as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh it's happened
they made it work cloud nine are your
a-league major champions
[Applause]
of course it was after winning the major
at the start of 2018 but things started
to kind of fall off a cliff for cloud9
from disbands to disasters to rebuilds
to roster drops to a multi-kajillion
dollar colossus that failed miserably
thanks in large part to kovid c9 sort of
understandably left csgo in the spring
of 2020 which i did a donate me about
coincidentally with the intention of
returning when pastures were greener and
apparently that time is now because what
better way to save north american
counterstrike than by slapping your
jersey on a group of tried and tested
europeans that's right folks cloud9's
brand spanking new cs go lineup is none
other than gambit so why and how did
this happen
well for starters they played for a
russian orc and if you watch the news at
any point in the last two months it
should be fairly obvious why that
matters if it isn't
i don't know ask your parents teachers
open a newspaper whatever needless to
say with tournament organizers like esl
banning russian orgs from participating
in their events in support of ukraine
and lineups like gambit and virtus pro
being forced to play under nameless
orgless banners
it sort of made sense that something
like this might happen but the second
reason
gambit are a really good team is it a
weird signing
i mean
yeah sorta just because cloud9 have kind
of always been about grass-fed locally
sourced n a talent
is it a good signing
i think it's an amazing assignment
literally like two days after the
signing went public cloud9 were able to
boast that they had a roster in the top
three of hltv's global rankings talk
about a uh we take those type situations
now you might be wondering to north
american fans are hobbit exile shiro
inters anaphony the most
marketable of personalities language
barrier aside i honestly think they
kinda are and i think if people stopped
begrudging them over the whole onliner
thing for half a second they'd probably
start to see how funny and endearing
these dudes can actually be but i also
think that when your roster is this good
it kinda sorta doesn't matter in just a
short period of time the now ex-gambit
players have already established
themselves as a group of hearty hardened
hopefuls who thrive in tier one european
cs something that actual north american
lineups have struggled to do for
well well forever but especially as of
late so instead of trying to assemble a
group of ragtag north american up and
comers or building a super team like
with the colossus jack c9's owner just
opted to buy a tried tested pre-packaged
deal
and he made sure to buy the whole
shebang coach analyst manager to ensure
that it stays untouched in terms of how
well this roster can do
i think it's fair to say that they'll
well
they'll win like they'll do well it's
gambit i can't say whether they'll win
the major since they're obviously still
quite young and obviously have a lot of
growing to do but i think it's fair to
say that with the support of a massive
tier one esports infrastructure
they can only get better a signing such
as this also has the potential to
attract both cloud9 specifically and
nacs at large
a ton of cis fans in fact if you look at
the comments on their announcement video
you can already see legions of fans
eastern european or otherwise expressing
thanks to c9 for essentially saving the
ex-gambit roster does this signing spell
great things for the future of north
american counter-strike
i mean it's hard to say they are still a
bunch of cis players at the end of the
day do we now as north americans have a
roster in the global top three rankings
and will there be usa chants when they
inevitably topple phase in a major final
god i hope so memes aside we shouldn't
underestimate the significance of having
yet another n a org in the like truly
upper echelon of competitive cs even if
it's in name only there are tons of na
kids who watch cloud9 compete in all
esports and watching them win in
counter-strike could inspire them to
start playing but until the next
stewie2k starts smoke-pushing his way
into the scene let's just take soulless
in the fact that a north american
mainstay is back and the judging by the
roster they signed
they're here to stay
it's just what we do danny it's what we
do all right
there's an old saying in n a dota that
if your team didn't have at least three
europeans on it you couldn't call
yourself an actual north american dota
team it was just it's just not proper
yeah
they only have two europeans like so
when are you going full name
[Music]